the first thing we're gonna do is
contracts between experts and expert
systems so expert systems as you can
tell are named after experts right it's
any kind of computer-based system
here's your definition right that it's
designed to mimic we'll get this picture
in a second it's designed to mimic the
intelligence and function of an expert
well I think myth-making is one of those
weird words where I think this Canon as
weird mimicked by itself just as mi mi
see and then maybe because when you take
away the cave
it looks like beam icing like icing on
the cake and remember anyway okay so now
just contrast this to some of the simple
things we were looking at before with
spreadsheets okay you don't necessarily
have to have any experts involved at all
when you're trying to say have a
spreadsheet decision support system that
works out someone's BMI and then tells
them okay what's their fitness level
doesn't really require tech so we could
all do that right whereas this is the
idea of an expert is someone who has to
have specialized training okay and
crucially years probably decades of
experience they've been doing something
a long time they're really really good
at making decisions and make it quickly
and making them accurately in a
particular area all right so this kind
of system decision support system is all
about trying to take all of that and
distill it down into some computer-based
system okay now the way we're going to
contrast between experts and expert
systems is to think about their
advantages expert systems over experts
and then think about their disadvantages
or another way
in other words ways that experts the
human ones are still superior to expert
systems okay now I've got a bunch of
pictures to help you trying to remember
these points that I'm going to go
through because I got quite a few I'm
gonna mainly dwell the advantages I
haven't found any pictures for the
disadvantages maybe you can do me a
favor and set up some of those okay so
let's go through these in order
advantages first of expert systems over
their human counterparts okay number one
this is my picture for ya accuracy is a
tricky one
okay I'm gonna element will deal with
accuracy in a minute I think you can
argue that an expert system versus an
expert might be more accurate might be
less what I was really trying to get out
with this and maybe you can tell me you
get a better picture is about
consistency okay okay so here's the
benefit of an expert system a
computer-based name right assuming it
has all the logical all the knowledge
programmed into it if it meets the same
situation okay this expert system
because it's a computer and all it's
doing is following rules and logic okay
it's gonna make the same decision again
and again and again
all right now later on we'll look at how
that's a disadvantage but you can you
see how that is an advantage all right
for instance have you ever been
frustrated when you get the exam back or
something like that you're looking at it
you're like oh I lost marks for this no
big deal because I made this particular
error and if you look over at your
friend and they made exactly the same
era they're working looks identical but
they didn't lose any marks what's wrong
with that
that's not fair right so consistency is
about the computer's ability to always
be following is understanding and its
knowledge and it's its rules for how it
makes decisions and always the same way
in every situation so that's a plus I'm
just human error you know we often say
when a when a marker is tired or when
someone is you know having a bad day or
something like that then consistency can
often go out the window right so humans
of this subjectivity can be a problem so
number one consistency number two any
takers
any takers elephants and morals
elephants of fairness will memory
push that was the Wow
nice nice work okay I don't think anyway
okay so what do I have in here well if
they say you know wow you got married
like an elephant
I suppose the opposite of a goldfish
what advantages does you can tell me
this right why does an expert system
have a memory advantage over an expert
thank you for stating the definition I'm
an exorcist okay so it's computer-based
so what what does it have to do with
memory yeah yeah yeah that's right
like I mean they say the working memory
of a human being is five objects five
items plus or minus two okay so if
you're pretty good you can get up to
seven things and if you're not so great
sort of do three things and the fourth
one you're like I can't remember okay so
that's the limitation of our short-term
memory our long-term memory is the same
I don't know what your memory is like
from say 10 years ago when you were like
five six years old
what kind of things do you remember
about now I only remember very very few
things mostly they're really traumatic
things right and then really because I
really enjoyed the rest of it it's just
gone
okay just quite a study because you talk
to a five or six year old like that they
know what's going on like they can speak
language they can read and so on but we
forget okay so short term and long term
memory computers have this tremendous
advantage okay but they've got
everything it's all equally accessible
to them right they never lose a due to
memory loss okay so there's a second
advantage third advantage a third
advantage is Zachary Quinto no way you
reckon this is dressed up as he's
playing Spock in Star Trek okay and
Spock is famous for live long across
Friday the businessman is characteristic
that his motivators for is logic all
right logic so if you've if should watch
the movies or you know the stories
there's sort of a big contrast between
spy and his counterpart the main
character of the series who is
captain cut the captain dude Captain
Kirk James Tiberius Kirk anyway
Captain Kirk is sort of a bit fly off
the handle loose cannon he's like I know
the logical thing to do but what feels
right you know he'll do things in that
kind of way whereas pot he's like look
these are the facts this is what we
should do this is the most appropriate
way we should go doesn't matter how you
feel you should do this okay so with an
expert system logic is very clear now
this is important if people are making
decisions you want to justify okay we
ought to spend this amount of money and
investing with this okay if you are a
business you want to be able to say okay
well is that worth doing and why is it
worth doing you want the reasons okay
now if you're like Captain Kirk you'll
be like because I felt like buying you
know that amount of stuff because you
know that day I don't it just feels
right or whatever okay
now that may be true it may be valid
even but it provides no explanation
right as opposed to when you go to an
expert system all of the rules and the
conditions and the understanding that
went into making a decision of making a
choice it's all very clear it's all laid
out there okay because it was programmed
in so logic in an expert system very
clear you could know why it made sent
decisions okay as opposed to you know
let's think about say a referee or a
referee on it a sport is generally an
expert your hope right so sometimes ref
makes a decision you're like why did
they do that what was the exact logic
behind it they like oh well I kind of
thought felt I got a nerve right whereas
the computer going to say look I've
measured this I saw that these are my
observations and here's the logic
underneath my decision okay so